so Tyler and I divorced I had a lot of
what's worse like I had a lot of
Whispers from Shaytards saying to me
like why would Allah do this to you like
the kind of things they say like all men
are dogs or women are dogs
so guys if you are somebody who trains
like me when I'm doing boxing when I'm
joking when I do bodybuilding this can
benefit you it's shinjit from Nature's
Blends as you guys know I get my honey
my black seed oil and many other
supplements from them it has 86 plus
minerals including zinc magnesium
selenium fulvic acid and 59 fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and save for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy it
too brothers and sisters and dear
friends before I start I want to praise
Allah the most for the most trust or
praise His glory and gratitude belong to
him so guys this video is pertaining to
a video my wife actually saw on YouTube
and she doesn't really follow the sister
but she came across it she was suggested
it and I watched the video myself
because as far as from what I know the
sister was married and but she has gone
through a divorce so Tyler and I divorce
we got divorced very soon after
Cathedral is born alhamdulillah it's
important to say alhamdulillah in a
tough time as well as our good times I
think because everything's done to Allah
and actually is watching a lecture from
mifflymac and he said that our divorces
are written for us so the same way our
marriage is written for us our divorces
are written for us so this divorce was
written for me before I was even here so
I can't complain alhamdulillah it's part
of my plan shaytan came to me strong but
the True Believers are strong with Allah
in their good times and their bad times
I had a lot of what's worse like I had a
lot of whispering saying to me like why
would Allah do this to you like the kind
of things they say like all men are dogs
or women are dogs yeah so a lot of us
want us about that and shaytan will
constantly come to me and say look
you're a single mom with a child no
man's ever going to want to be with you
and that's it you lost your chance to
ever start a family you know all these
kind of things
um and yes a lot of men are not going to
want to be with me that's okay I don't
want to be with every man
um that would be weird
um but there will be somebody out there
for me inshallah and pertaining to this
brother and sister subhanallah it's very
sad because one of the reasons I started
the bitter truth Show the marriage
documentary and other things that I'm
working on in behind the scenes is all
pertaining to combat this issue which is
pertaining to the break down of the
family unit so I'm heavily trying my
best to help an aid to keep the marriage
unit in tax inshallah but it's hard to
hear these things and these things do
happen it doesn't mean that the person
is bad who goes through divorce divorce
can happen to anybody it doesn't make
the person be the male or the female
going for a divorce that there was
something wrong with them it can mean
that but it doesn't necessarily mean
that's always the case divorces happen
because of mismatch you're just not
getting on with one another variety of
reasons also divorce sometimes happens
for very Petty and unneeded reasons
Eagles get in the way or whatever it may
be and divorce happens for those reasons
sadly minor city is the following I know
that she needs manasia or I'm a nobody
or I don't even need to do a video about
this issue but when I see these things
there's a couple of things that we can
benefit from which is firstly brothers
and sisters when it comes to these
issues we need to understand something
very clearly any public figure for that
matter I always tell them and I'm not
saying directly this was the cause I'm
not saying that I'm just giving a
general Nasir make sure that you are
praying and given the right to Allah
fast things zakar had whatever it may be
saying everyone major sins sins have a
direct correlation to issues at home
like I said before this doesn't
necessarily mean every marital dispute
or divorce that ends like this is
connected to this I'm not saying that
there were men prophets of Allah who
married women who were evil and there
were amazing women who married men like
or evil so Allah can test you but
sometimes Roman sisters you need to
understand that there is a connection in
the sense of what that our sins have an
impact so much the self would say that
if I was to come into sin outside and I
would come home and see my wife for some
reason angry shouting whatever he said I
will connect it to a sin that I
committed so they understood what the
consequences the sins can have and
that's why Allah says in Surah Yusuf
that the thali mean will never be
successful the oppressors don't
suppressed they will never be successful
so Allah is tying Those who commit sins
to not being successful so these things
can have an impact number two as a
public figure doing your eskar it is
very important for you to do your it is
very very important because if you don't
do Epcot you are prone to the danger of
the metaphysical world and people are
jealous people have envy people don't
like you they see her there's magic
there's all kinds of stuff involved so
please please make sure if you're a
public figure you do your Healthcare it
is fundamental and it is vital to do
that now besides all of this like I said
before my dear sister I haven't we've
heard your side of the story we've only
started the brother again I don't know
this doesn't mean you are guilty or he
is guilty or you're innocent or he is
innocent when it comes to these issues
brothers and sisters when you look from
an outside don't blame people oh it must
be the husband the husband must be bad
or it must be no you don't know the
Dynamics do not make judgment you don't
know nothing just because a brother you
see a brother crying doesn't mean he's
not guilty or you see a sister crying
doesn't mean she's not guilty so please
bear that in mind when you're looking at
these kind of things and protect your
marriage please try my dear brothers and
sisters public figures to not show your
marital life to everybody well like
especially if you're not doing it at
card try your best and I'm not saying
this was the course I'm talking in
general try to keep your life private
there was actually a study done that
those who keep their lives private they
are more happy than those who blast it I
know of in the individuals one brother
who who was in the prison cell accused
of r-a-p-e yes falsely the charge will
drop and if you went to the Instagram
page you would never in the millionaires
think these people have this problem
because this face fake persona and the
lifestyle that we put out there it's not
real so in a nutshell to the brother or
the sister going through divorce
whatever it may be inshallah may Allah
make it for easy for both of you guys
learn lessons from this inshallah and
you never know may Allah may bring you
guys back together again it's impossible
in Islam it is allowed but please bear
that in mind and in general my dear
system may I make it easy for you may I
make it easy for your husband too you
know you know I'm sure he's going
through stuff as well as much as you are
and inshallah that you guys can be there
for your kids and be there for that
child inshallah which is very important
and do not lose hope in Allah and
inshallah Allah will give something
better to both of you guys I just
forgive the general reminder inshallah
so in a nutshell brothers and sisters uh
please do not lose hope those who are
divorced inshallah do not lose hope
these things happen it can make you
better and you can learn from your
mistakes inshallah and may Allah make
the Affairs of our sister easy it was
just a general nasia inshallah and may
Allah bless us all and guide us all and
protect us from the harms of evil eye
Hazard and say hi and whatever it may be
please please do you have card and ask
Allah guidance and keep your lives
inshallah private to the best of the
ability to